esta demócrata como alcalde mayor que
fue descrita como la capital del crimen
se había convertido para los años 90 la
ciudad grande más segura del país ahora
hoy mi ciudad está en shock
con crimen violento asesinatos y robos
están aumentando a unas tasas que no se
habían escuchado en el pasado vemos el
retorno de los saqueos y los disturbios
durante esos momentos este alcalde ha
evitado que la policía haga arrestos e
incluso cuando se hacen esos arrestos
los progresistas liberan a estos
saqueadores los neoyorquinos se
preguntan cómo nos abrumó el crimen de
manera tan rápida y subió tan rápido no
permitan que los demócratas le hagan
eeuu lo que le han hecho nueva york de
nuevo los demócratas les están pidiendo
que voten por un candidato defectuoso
spider ha cambiado sus principios tantas
veces que ya no tiene principio alguno y
es un caballo de troya con bernie con
ellos y con pelos y con la claves mater
y su país su partido está completamente
tirado a la izquierda para ejecutar su
agenda socialista y anti policía
esta ola comienza con una causa justa el
imperdonable asesinato de georges boy de
minneapolis y las manifestaciones
pacíficas comenzaron en todo el país
la combinación del asesinato la condena
fue universal desde donde hasta los
líderes demócratas parecía durante unos
pequeños momentos cortos que demócratas
y republicanos se iban a unir con una
propuesta unificada para reducir este
tipo de comportamientos por parte de la
policía esta posibilidad era muy
peligrosa para la izquierda tenían un
país que destruido
esta acción en contra de la policía
sería muy valiosa y haría que el
presidente camps se viera como un líder
efectivo no querían nada de eso entonces
la clase mater y antigua entraron en
acción y de manera rápida se tomaron
estas protestas y las convirtieron en
disturbios violentos pronto las
manifestaciones se convirtieron en
motines y revueltas en ciudades
prácticamente lideradas todas por
demócratas las personas golpeadas
disparos de oficiales de la policía
atacados y golpeados y a veces
asesinados y la policía se vio atada por
los alcaldes demócratas que simplemente
observaban los crímenes y recibían los
golpes
con el asesinato de personas inocentes
que tenían toda su vida por delante el
asesinato de tal afar de cuatro años en
kansas chocó a todo el país pero no a
black letters ni a sus
seguidores demócratas brandon hendrix
igualmente fue asesinado en el bronx
días después de graduarse de la
secundaria y en camino a sam jones para
jugar basquetbol falleció y apenas lo
mencionaron un niño de un año de boca
juniors fue
asesinado en sus coches y eso no causó
ningún tipo de escándalo al presidente
camps y para nosotros republicanos todas
las vidas negras importan y las vidas de
grande prenden y de thiago importan para
nosotros todas importan
estos disturbios que continúan en las
ciudades demócratas dan una buena vista
del futuro bajo una administración byd
en todas las top 5 de las ciudades para
los robos y los saqueos están gobernadas
por demócratas progresistas que están
utilizando este enfoque para el crimen
que es básicamente no hacer nada en
lugar de reducirlo liberar prisioneros
tantos como puedan y entrar en guerra
con la policía el único grupo que tiene
la capacidad de proteger a nuestros
ciudadanos
es claro que un voto por byd en y por
los demócratas crea el riesgo de que
ustedes traigan este tipo de
comportamientos a sus ciudades a su
suburbio ya su pueblo
no hay duda de que este elemento trabajo
de restaurar la seguridad para el pueblo
no puede hacerse desde el sótano joe
entonces tampoco hay duda que el
presidente camps
va a luchar con toda su fuerza para
preservar el sistema de gobierno y
nuestra manera de vida y en momentos
críticos de nuestra historia eeuu
siempre se ha visto bendecida con la
persona correcta para atender la crisis
washington lincoln roosevelt reagan
fueron perfectos para los retos que
enfrentaron y llevaron a esta nación de
manera en su gloriosa el presidente
camps con su amor sin límites por el
país y por nuestro pueblo
su ética de trabajo disciplinada su
habilidad excepcional para inspirar y su
entendimiento del sistema de gobierno y
su respeto por los valores
estadounidenses es un hombre que podemos
confiar para mejorar nuestra manera de
vida señor presidente haga que nuestra
nación sea segura de nuevo